[Musique]
pensez vous que l'on puisse rattraper
cent vingt ans de retard dans le domaine
automobile et des voitures électriques
nous avons cent vingt ans de retard
l'histoire automobile avait pourtant
très bien commencé au début du 20e
siècle
nos grands parents nos
arrière-grands-parents ou plus encore
avait la possibilité de s'acheter une
voiture thermique ou une voiture
électrique
moi ça m'a surpris il pouvait donc
s'acheter une voiture à essence une
voiture thermique que nous la
connaissons aujourd'hui bruyante mais
démarrage à la manivelle ou alors une
voiture électrique silencieuse et
démarrage au bouton mais face au
lobbying pétrolier à la recherche d'une
plus grande autonomie et l'innovation du
haj le thermique à gagner à tel point
que la voiture électrique avait
quasiment disparu
bon enfin presque
mais aujourd'hui la voiture électrique
revient en force
notre volonté de réduire notre
consommation de carburant notre volonté
de réduire des émissions de co2 nous
incite à revenir à cette alternative
comment allons-nous pouvoir migrer
rapidement notre parc automobile
thermique en électrique
je suis aymeric libos et je suis un
digital activistes
certains pourraient associer ce terme
digital à ses 25 ans de ma vie passée
dans cette extraordinaire aventure
entrepreneuriale et industriels dans
l'informatique ou en commençant à 5
on est aujourd'hui plus de mille dans le
monde nan nan nan nan nan pendant ce
n'est pas ce digital la dent je parle
c'est celui qui impacte profondément nos
habitudes nos consommations et nos
déplacements
on le vit tous les jours et activiste
car je m'engage je partage mes
convictions je cherche à faire agir je
vais essayer de vous faire agir
l'histoire le début de l'histoire
c'est ce 6 juillet 2010 est notre ex
ministre de la transition écologique
annonce son plan climat et la fin à la
vente des véhicules thermiques pour 2040
2040 mais
qui réfléchit à cette échéance ce n'est
pas un horizon qui nous touche
vous me croirez si vous voulez mais à ce
moment là j'ai entendu cette phrase
historique plein d'ambition de jfk
we choose to go to the moon vous savez
ce projet improbable voire même
impossible ou sa seule réussite passera
par la recherche de nouvelles solutions
mais 2040
on va encore se retrouver en 2038 pour
chercher des solutions
c'est à ce moment là qu'est né le projet
twenty show band transformons nos
voitures thermiques en voiture
électrique pour agir maintenant et pour
le plus grand nombre
c'est ma contribution à cet enjeu auquel
je crois très sincèrement
de leur côté des constructeurs
automobiles ont leurs contraintes
industrielles
si demain une grande majorité d'entre
vous convaincu par les lits par les
voitures électriques
cherchez à acheter une voiture neuve ils
ne pourraient pas suivre le rythme en
il est difficilement concevable
d'attendre de longs mois ou plusieurs
années pour recevoir sa voiture et en
2000 il faut passer ses échéances de
comment ceux qui resteront qui seront
toujours au thermique supporteront-ils
leur statut social de vieux pollueurs
vous l'aurez compris ce projet est une
offre complémentaire à celle des
constructeurs automobiles pour agir
maintenant et pour vous préparer à
l'électrique
si je suis ici avec vous aujourd'hui
c'est pour vous parler de solution si
l'on veut agir vite
faisons avec ce que l'on a nos voitures
existantes
transformons nos voitures existantes
allonger leur durée de vie
si l'on veut agir vite nous devons nous
autoriser des pertes acceptables
ces changements ne seront pas
transparent nous devons accepter des
changements
ce projet est un ensemble de nouvelles
expériences de vie avec sa voiture
concrètement en quelques heures on
extrait le moteur thermique la voiture
et on le remplace par un moteur
électrique et ses batteries
cela apporte une autonomie de 100 km et
une vitesse maximale de 110 km/heure
l'économie de co2 et direct une zone 3
par an si on réduit les émissions de co2
ne négligeons pas non plus la réduction
de la pollution sonore sur le volet
financier
l'économie va dépasser 1000 euros par an
est la question que certains pour
exposer cette transformation un coût de
5000 euros pour agir pour le plus grand
nombre
ça c'est la première expérience
ce n'est pas parce qu'un du retard qu'il
ne faut pas prendre de l'avancé
la seconde expérience et de connecter sa
voiture pour se faire accompagner dans
sa conduite
nous devons optimiser notre conduite
je suis l'heureux conducteur d'une
voiture hybride ma conduite a changé
j'ai appris seul à freiner plus
doucement mais plus longtemps pour
récupérer l'énergie
j'ai appris seul à lâcher l'accélérateur
plus de cent mètres avant de m'arrêter
pour récupérer l'énergie
toutes ces énergies recharge la batterie
et cela peut représenter jusqu'à 30%
ne gâchons pas cette énergie je suis en
or les adopteurs un pionnier
je le sais mais c'est pour cela que je
suis convaincu qu'il faut se faire
accompagner dans sa conduite pour
apprendre plus vite et ensuite on pourra
même comparé ces consommations d'un
trajet un autre une grande partie
d'entre nous sait conduire une voiture
thermique
apprenons à conduire une voiture
électrique
la dernier
l'expérience est une recharge sans
contact si je réduis l'autonomie de ma
voiture je vais devoir me recharger plus
souvent là je me gare à la bonne place
ma voiture se recharge je n'ai rien à
faire et c'est très simple là je vous
entends déjà réagir alors ce soit très
clair entre nous et j'adore quand vous
réagissez oui mais ses batteries la leur
fabrication c'est catastrophique en co2
oui mais c'est possible de faire ça de
transformer une voiture thermique en
voiture électrique
d'abord la réponse la plus excitante
pour la première fois aujourd'hui au
tedx de la rochelle
cette voiture est maintenant une voiture
électrique c'est le premier prototype
d'une série de voitures citadines
[Applaudissements]
je n'oublie évidemment pas la question
par rapport aux batteries oui oui c'est
vrai fabriquer des batteries aimé du co2
mais par quoi faut-il commencer attendre
qu'il ait de nouvelles technologies de
batteries pour faire de la voiture
électrique ont commencé à transformer le
parc thermique en électrique
moi j'ai fait mon choix transformons nos
voitures électriques thermiques en
voiture électrique
maintenant donner une seconde vie à nos
voitures pour agir maintenant
ne faisons pas la moitié du chemin
avec quelle énergie
je vais pouvoir recharger cette voiture
il faut se préoccuper de l'origine de
l'électricité qu'on utilise aujourd'hui
cela a du sens il y à de nombreux
opérateurs qui savent prêt à porter de
l'énergie renouvelable
challandes journée cela a du sens neuneu
déplaçons pas le problème de co2 de la
mobilité à la production électricité
sans conteste la meilleure énergie est
celle que l'on ne consomme pas vient
ensuite l'énergie que l'on va produire
localement avec ses panneaux solaires
ces éoliennes et puis enfin l'énergie
renouvelable injecté dans le réseau
il y à une légende qui dit que l'on ne
peut pas se passer du nucléaire
brison cette légende en nous préoccupant
de l'origine de l'électricité
je vous entends encore réagir oui mais
c'est où ce projet c'est dans toute
l'europe
je suis un européen j'ai grandi avec
je me suis battu pour et en europe nous
devons penser à l'échelle européenne
oui mais c'est où je vais vous partagez
1 et rêve je rêve de faire la
transformation de ces voitures dans les
garages de la marque sur un corner
vous savez ce sont ces petits espaces
pour une marque réservée dans l'espace
d'une plus grosse marque comme on peut
le voir dans les grands magasins
et là nous aurons les deux pieds dans
cette ère digitale avec cette démarche
en collaboration au début je vous
partagez mon analyse de 120 ans de
retard en digital activistes convaincu
que les solutions sont là maintenant
accessible au plus grand nombre
je sais que j'ai commencé ma part et
vous nous n'avons pas de planète b
agissons agissons pour ne pas constater
ensemble 150 ans de retard changez votre
je veux part j'ai changé votre je veux
changer le monde part j'ai changé le
monde
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]